curse comments curse comments is the
worst subreddit a wise man Point proven
cursed worker can I get a McDonald's
very funny I worked at your store in
Sussex for three years and stole over
10K from the register without anyone
noticing no one noticed 10K music
can I get a a 10K my new stepmom is
younger than oh no stepmom
well this weekend my dad married his
girlfriend my parents got divorced over
my dad cheating with her
24 and my new Step was 20. so there's
that and I'm not sure what exactly I'm
feeling right now
does she have a dad
Fight Fire With Fire
come on man don't be a beta it's the
only way to get back maybe if we didn't
give serial killers such a cool names
like The Night Stalker and instead we
call them small PP killer that's me
that's my title everyone knows it
cookie it actually requires a lot of
accuracy we'd have less serial killers
that's sad
you're not wrong if you just won 30
million and your mom's left eye costs 29
million what do you do
I heard Lamborghini and an eye patch
let's ride next year
oh God
I didn't I didn't read next year that's
that was the top of the cream very nice
me I don't think I'll ever experience
culture shock while on holiday the Dutch
toilet
wait what's the problem with it
is it
oh
Dutch people explain yourself now
how do you sit on the toilet as a fellow
Dutchman I can oh God this is gonna be
bad
anytime a comment starts with fellow
Dutchman it's never good I can say that
these toilets are notoriously known for
causing so-called bag slab
Dutch people this is a rare phenomenon
which can happen when a turd is so solid
it stands up straight only to collapse
stop panel Dutch people you're all
banned from this channel I'm starting
with the channel hit the pause and
destroy everything in his path terrible
experience why did you make the toilets
like that I would actually sit the wrong
way on that I don't want a bank sniper
catch me dead before I get a Dutch bag
slapper on me God damn God ugh I don't
want to continue
never in my life heard a story about a
hamster dying peacefully it's always
some crazy-ish what my sister ate mine
what that's not no no don't eat
hamstrings Pro tip words of wisdom from
PewDiePie you're welcome you should eat
your sister then it's only fair uh I'm
high as hell just discovered I can fit
way more dino nuggets in my air fryer if
I put them vertically
it's not bad just had a great idea for
cemeteries
that's not bad why not why not I always
thought that when I was a kid I was like
how does it fit everyone oh it makes
sense
I still think that how do they fit
everyone
graveyard diggers I know you're watching
lemon I don't explain you dig up old
people that's why they're called
graveyard diggers they
it all makes sense
smart after all that's right it's
because I'm wearing the glasses today
the entire Sonic 2 movie was uploaded to
XVideos
why were you searching Sony in XVideos
explain yourself right now I mean that
original 3D image
I ain't a furry but
what the hell
make a pattern with your first and third
emoji and let's see how cute it is
here's mine
if
smoking emojis giving BJ to Shrek while
telling
well I can never unsee that emoji now
stop it Frank I want to see what mine is
oh generic I apologize
[Music]
dude is that Crystal Around Jesus Christ
gallery of Duty Rainbow Six sense
I gotta check it's the first thing that
shows up didn't he say he would stop oh
boy
nothing's changed huh anyway cursed
vegans vegans block access for customers
wanting milk in targeted multi-sealy
protests that's why dad has taken so
long that is just he really went out to
get milk
but these goddamn vegans
kept in going for years
they just wouldn't leave the daily dose
of Internet so YouTube do monetize my
new video because I showed a plan
uh we'll look into it and show her back
with an update eight hours later
confirming that we're still looking into
it and we'll get back to you soon
okay all right I love the update we're
still looking into it we're still
looking into it uh still looking
name anime character who can defeat
Master away six plastic straws Checkmate
Master ugly you're weak pathetic Japan
had plastic straws when I first came
here but then now they started with the
paper and life is just worse thanks
Turtles thanks Master ugly idiot what
are some guy Secrets girls don't know
about we can't move our PP without
closing our button oh wow
you just made men all over the Internet
clenched her ass that's power you can't
[Music]
ever thought of that
interesting this is this should be that
important knowledge to know subreddit
tell me a cursed Fact one curse fact is
that there's a genetic disorder called
fibroid dysplasia top also known as
Stone Man suit that causes the body soft
tissues to gradually turn into bone over
time
it's like Naruto this includes muscles
tendons ligaments which eventually
become rigid and immobil effectively
turn the person into your living statue
there's currently no known cure for fob
and the average size one of those
disorder is only about 40 years
pop why why can't some diseases be like
superpowers why do everything just gonna
suck oh that is Curse I'm not don't
Google it I know you're going to be
trust it's not worth it oh yeah you
can't tell me jokes but you can tell me
cursing from screw you AI selling my
female mannequin my daughter doesn't
want it freaks her out I want to get
back my money best offer I'll give you a
hundred dollars to tell her it's sold
hide it in the attic for two weeks take
it out and put it back in the room while
she's sleeping
ah I can't wait to be in the head it
seems so much fun
legally terrorize someone
don't do that that's horrible I don't
think I'll ever mature
I'll I'll never be too old for cursed
comments anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
as well sorry I haven't uploaded that
much lately but I hope to get back on
the horse I've been doing some other
stuff
see you guys in the next one bye bye
node VPN greatest VPN
man that's how passionate I am about
nordvpn you all know what a VPN is y'all
know why you should use it but let me
tell you what norvpn is better than all
the other ones they truly care about
your security with amazing features like
threat protection always protecting you
no matter what Bing Bang Boom they're
constantly working on new features to
keeping you safe now introducing dark
web monitor dark web that's a scary
place with one click you're protected
from dark web previously if you sign up
to a website and that website gets
compromised all your information is
leaked and you're likely to not even
know about it but with the dark red
monitor what it does is that nordvpn is
constantly checking this for you now all
you have to do is Click dark web monitor
on and boom nordvpn is constantly
scanning for new compromise links to see
if you are in Epic danger just click it
on and you don't even have to worry
about it one of many amazing features
with nordvpn you really should be good
you really should you should VPN nordvpn
nordvpn truly cares about you more than
your dad does
oh well anyway and right now if you sign
up with the link in the description
nordvpn.com PewDiePie for a two-year
deal you get additional four months for
free it's risk-free with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee
all you have to do is check out the link
in description when you sign up to get
this offer don't just go to nordvpn.com
and sign up and then oh I could have
used PewDiePie's link he would have
gotten me the extra special deal in four
months for free use the leg you dummy